I gotta tell the audience I think
Ronnie's officially out of uh sex tips
because he just did a whole bunch of sex
tips for Christmas and I listened to him
last night and every one of them is
basically take the weirdest [ __ ]
thing you can find stick it in your ass
you know Ronnie I admit you ran out of
him this time but what are you talking
about I'll give you evidence Bonnie let
me present to the jury since we got a
jury here
it's going already so no you'll see
everything just goes in your [ __ ] and
some of these things I don't even dude
where do you want it to go in my ear you
wanted to go over my ear for God's sakes
you're out of your mind you never did
this listen to this oh Merry Christmas
lovers I'm gonna tell you how to make a
very special dildo it's called the
eggnog dildo oh baby get yourself a
quart of eggnog get an old style ice
tray and just pour a bunch of eggnog
into the tray and put it in your freezer
let it freeze overnight
and when it's all Frozen take a nice big
knife and cut long slices down the
middle lately little dildos you know
what I'm saying then take it real quick
and stick it into your lady's [ __ ] or
your man's [ __ ] and watch it melt and
then just eat it out and enjoy Merry
Christmas lovers
okay you said it was an old school ice
tray so to me that's the cubes right no
no no no you don't you don't put that
part eight of it that part of it in you
didn't say that so I'm already confused
okay so now you got the whole tray and I
turned the tray over and then I get a
knife and a hammer eggnog you know what
we'll cut a lot easier than [ __ ] ice
it will first well first of all have you
ever really done it no don't worry about
what I've done all right
now you need an ice pick to [ __ ] your
wife
we're gonna [ __ ] but but and also it's
like well first you take it and you cut
it in here and you stick it in a pushy
you need 48 Hours of preparation I've
never had any [ __ ] fun man I'm sorry
dude did you ever try sucking on a
[ __ ] Lifesaver and then eating out
getting eaten out by that you ever put
Alka-Seltzer in your [ __ ] Robin
you never put Skittles in your ass and
shoot them across the room you you keep
to your stuff I'll keep to mind so you
might want to put a bird bath in my ass
that's my business
sex and food Ronnie must get hungry
during sex because a lot of this has to
do with food this tip involves first you
take a pineapple
this involves a chocolate truffle ball
oh yeah Merry Christmas lovers get
yourself a chocolate truffle ball oh and
then you stick it and your girl's
[ __ ] or your boy's [ __ ] and then
that will be a butt plug or his butt
plug and then can I stop this for a
second isn't eating chocolate out of
someone's ass a good way to accidentally
eat a turd run oh stop it 100 not all
the way it like up is it all the way up
in his [ __ ]
be careful Stephanie that's not Bosco
it's like it's like a butt plug you
remember yeah
he tried it out on me it was great don't
act like you don't know oh she says to
you I want you to eat my butt plug you
can just start nibbling on that
chocolate truffle ball oh my god it
feels so good oh
oh wow yeah Merry Christmas well I'll
give you this that was very inclusive
because no matter what gender you are
everyone has an [ __ ] and I applaud
Ronnie for uh thinking forward like that
that's right should I play your Hanukkah
sex tip because you didn't want to leave
the Jews out
in your ass
take a guess
Ronnie's Hanukkah tips
you felt the fish up there right
calm down your ass is like a
refrigerator
you take a bagel and lox sandwich and
you shove it up your ears
to all my Jewish friends after happy
Hanukkah and now I'm going I'm going to
tell you something really cool to do
with a very easy thing to find and it's
called the dreidelity you take your
little Dreidel Dreidel and you spread
the woman's legs open and you find a
little clitoris and you take it and you
put a little bit of Lube on the just the
tip of it and you spin it around on a
clip
she'll come like the Moon
oh wet this was a great sex tip for
Hanukkah
you know what you're doing dreidel spins
on a clip
have you tried it you don't know
anything
Robin you know what I'm gonna do here
you don't know anything I'm gonna insert
a gross thing into another gross thing
he's the Jewish thing you put up your
ass you guys have no imagination I'm
sorry
ah